Hey, David, if Joe Biden manages to win Florida
back from Trump, is it over for Donald Trump?
So I understand why people are asking this.
Florida is a big prize electorally.
It's 29 electoral votes.
And right now, Joe Biden is leading by an
average of six point four in Florida.
That's a range of anywhere from being tied
in Florida to Biden, plus 10 in Florida.
The real Clear Politics average in Florida
right now is that Biden is up by six point
four.
So let's start with just the simple mathematical
case.
If you start with the 2016 map where Trump
won Florida and the only change you make is
you flip Florida to Biden.
That is not enough for Joe Biden to win the
presidency.
Biden winning Florida and otherwise, the map
staying is 27.
2016 would give Trump 277 still.
You only need 270 to be president.
So Florida alone will not help Joe Biden win.
However.
These elections rarely are completely isolated,
where everything is the same as 2016 except
one state flips, if Biden wins Florida, he
probably is going to win something else.
Like, for example, Wisconsin, Michigan or
Pennsylvania.
If Biden wins Florida back and Wisconsin,
he wins.
If Biden wins Florida, back in Michigan, he
wins.
If Biden wins Florida and Pennsylvania back,
he also wins.
And even if Trump holds Florida, so Trump
keeps Florida and keeps Ohio, Biden can still
win by winning any two of the three states,
Wisconsin, Michigan and Pennsylvania.
Now, of course, there's other opportunities
for Joe Biden as well.
Arizona is very much in play for Joe Biden.
North Carolina is close.
So in the mathematical sense alone, Florida
only will not do it for Joe Biden.
My belief is that if we see Joe Biden win
in Florida, he will certainly win some other
state that I mentioned.
There's almost an exact analysis to be made
in Ohio.
The difference is Ohio's only 18 electoral
votes, whereas Florida's twenty nine.
So if Biden flips Ohio, but not Florida, he's
still likely needs Ohio plus two, unless it's
a very high population state with more electoral
votes.
Now, in the end, we've got 50 elections.
We can't control anything other than our one
vote and we have to make sure to use it.
So when I look at these scenarios, you know,
every once in a while I will look at 270 to
win.
Dot com is a great place where you can start
with the 2016 map and say, okay, we start
with 2016 and flip this or flip that.
There's a bunch of different scenarios that
have Biden winning.
There's one scenario that has a tie.
I believe it's 269 269 and a bunch of scenarios
that have Trump winning.
All I can do is vote.
And so when I cast my ballot via absentee,
which I've already requested in the state
of Massachusetts, I will be doing it with
the belief that.
This state could come down to my vote.
It is mathematically unlikely to be that way.
But every single one of us should say.
Would I vote if my vote could be the difference
maker?
Of course, your vote could be the difference
maker, meaning, yes, you should vote.
And we all need to make sure that we do